die sache mit der der etwas noten für
deutschland sag ich immer mache ich so
ich bin mindestens für für deutschland
so gefährlich wie der adwords noten für
amerika zu knoten setzte sich allerdings
nach russland ab rainer hoffmann tauchte
vor sechs jahren in der schweiz unter
knoten legte sich mit den us
geheimdiensten hoffmann mit der
solarindustrie
also ist ein ganz wichtiges ding
halbieren sie ihre heizkosten
das war aus dem jahr 2005 da war das
also immer noch so erfahren wir haben
sie also richtig damit geworben dass man
mit einem solar kollektor die heizkosten
halbieren könnte und da ist auch nichts
im kleingedruckten was man hier steht im
kleingedruckten mögliches
einsparpotenzial so also dort haben sie
auch hier das weiß auch vollmundigen
versprechungen skepsis angebracht ist
wurde hoffmann erst klar als es schon zu
spät war 1996 entschied er sich in
seinem haus eine solarthermie anlage zu
installieren womit diese tragödie ihren
anfang nahm
das ist das ursprüngliche inselrat vom
1996 und da ist eben der slogan drin
lassen sie sich nicht erzählen
solaranlagen für brauchwasser seien
technisch nicht ausgereift oder zu teuer
wenn sie ihre heizung neu planen dann
planen sie die sonne mit ein
es lohnt sich für sie und unsere umwelt
60 bis 70 prozent ihres
warmwasserbedarfs können sie auch in
deutschland mit einer solar
nagl decken wärme direkt ab solle
hoffmann ist nicht der einzige der sich
täuschen ließ ich kann es nicht genau
sagen es kommt auch darauf an wie viel
ertrag man dass man sagt im durchschnitt
70 prozent des jahresbedarfs kann man
denken und das lässt sich dann zeigen
ich sag mal wie auch der sommer wird
umso besser natürlich auch die
energieausbeute
er hatte den schwindel nicht geschnallt
dass zum einen im sommer nur ein
bruchteil der energie des energiebedarfs
generiert wird den mann ersetzen könnte
mit einer solaranlage und er weiß nicht
dass sich die 70 prozent eben nicht auf
den gesamten heizbedarf beziehen sondern
auf das trinkwasser das nur um zehn
prozent der heizwärme kosten ausmacht
wir fahren nach recklinghausen in
nordrhein-westfalen in hoffmanns heimat
hier leitete er die finanzbuchhaltung
eines kmu bis irgendwann alles aus dem
ruder lief seinen kampf gegen die
solarindustrie hat er teuer bezahlt sein
haus gehört heute einem anderen da auch
doch er hat ja noch ein stück solar dran
gemacht
an dieses ding werde ich immer abgelehnt
hatte weil dort keine keine südseite ist
das ist nur westseite nordwestseite das
bringt ja gar nichts ich hatte da auch
noch hin gemacht sie haben alles
verloren sind die autos verloren hat
sich der kampf gut schon insofern für
die erkenntnis auf jeden fall wie
schlecht es um diesen staat bestellt ist
um zu erkennen wie eigentlich politisch
gehupt das ganze system ist und gerade
in bezug auf diese ganze öko wirtschaft
das wurde dann bewusst proben hat sich
gelohnt dass ihre ganze existenz
gebracht
man darf doch nicht akzeptieren dass das
leute aus zwei und 2 5 machen wenn man
das denn dann ist man doch im grunde
mittäter wenn man das auf sich beruhen
lässt tragische höhepunkt war die
polizei vor seinem haus stand und ihn
verhaften wollte es wird aus gewesen
wie wollen sie denn haben wollen sie
denn eigentlich hier
das können wir zu und das können wir
jetzt so nicht machen da sehen sie doch
machen sie die tür wieder auf wenn sie
hier nicht verschwinden springe ich nach
unten machen so werden hintergehen mich
dass deshalb alle leute hier mitgekriegt
genau ich komme jetzt runter ja erlahmt
der hauptmann sehen sie dass ich mich
ordentlich ausgewiesen habe ich kann
mich das ganze hier hofft man landet die
für eine woche in der geschlossenen
psychiatrie wo ich mein querulanten
waren diagnostiziert wurde
[Applaus]
seine rechtshändel fingen harnos an
bereichert er weigerte sich die in
seinen augen mangelhafte solaranlage
vollständig zu bezahlen und bestand
darauf opfer eines betruges geworden zu
sein
das gericht entschied gegen ihn eine
täuschung des beklagten liegt nicht vor
in seiner werbeanzeige hat der kläger
nicht die behauptung aufgestellt dass
auch 60 bis 70 prozent des wärmebedarfs
der heizung durch solarenergie gedeckt
werden können
es entspricht nicht der
verkehrsauffassung unter
warmwasserbedarf auch den wärmebedarf
für die erwärmung des heizungs wassers
zu verstehen von brauchwasser der raum
zeige ist die mutter keine rede
für außenstehende ein detail für
hoffmann der entscheidende punkt in
einem anderen urteil spricht ein anderes
gericht nämlich in zusammenhang mit dem
wasser im heizungs kreislauf von
brauchwasser
darum habe er recht findet hoffmann aber
die justiz wollte das partout nicht
einsehen
obwohl es den den tatbestand des der
richter beleidigung nicht gibt es
insofern aber wenn sie richtern fehler
nachweisen dann ist das ein angriff auf
ihre eitelkeit und dann ticken die durch
das ticken die durch das ist ein guter
ton jetzt schnell weg hier aus der nähe
des amtsgerichts
es war die ouvertüre für eine ganze
reihe von prozessen die hoffmann fast
alle verloren
es sei kein querulant sagt hoffmann
sondern vielmehr ein unnachgiebiger
kämpfe für die wahrheit der alles
verloren hat gründen sie mal auf
immerhin eine gute freundin ist ihm
geblieben
vorstehen doch sie sehen doch gut aus
sie sehen doch gut aus da können sie
auch mit ihrer ihrer nichte teil
und hier eine ganz schöne sache eine
ganz schön sei hier ganz schöne
praktische sache
jetzt bei den winter schön für die
handtasche für unterwegs
silber gibt es unter www standen sofort
am fenster beim amtsgericht und herrn
wieder geguckt und die summe die
behalten waren frühere arbeitskollegen
und blieben sich auch nach hoffmanns
flucht in die schweiz verbunden
ich kann nur gutes sagen er hat immer
viel geduld gehabt und ein guter kollege
das kann ich nur immer sagen und sich ja
wir haben immer noch kontakt das ist gut
so gut so wie sie da raus und dann ist
da natürlich auch noch seine mutter wo
bist du bist du zu hause ja ab 2 uhr
bist du dann kommen wir um 2 uhr
ja ja aber sagt hat kein sagt hat keine
so wie gesagt so jetzt sagt es kein sack
ist geil so hoffmann fürchtet die
behörden könnten auf ihn aufmerksam
werden
trotzdem waren wir einen spaziergang
durch recklinghausen einen großen
freundeskreis hat er nicht als er noch
hier lebte und im laufe seines kampfes
wendeten sich immer mehr menschen von
ihm ab galileo galilei aber auch ein
eigenbrötler jetzt waren alle irgendwo
eigenbrötler sagt siegfried tradition ja
wenn man wenn man sich intensiv mit
irgendeiner materie beschäftigt dann
steckt man eben mehr drin als andere
und dann hat man auch in ganz anderen
überblick und dann und willig sind die
note liegt das
naja da lasse ich nicht so gelten den
tunnelblick denen das ich nicht nicht
sogar ich habe mir gerne kritik anderer
an wenn endlich konnte bis jetzt jeden
widerlegen der irgendwo versucht hat
gegenargument zu haben
das konnte ich ja alles widerlegen dass
das was behauptet worden ist nicht
stimmte so symbolisch hoffmann wurde zum
verhängnis dass er verbreitete der
solaranbieter sei ein betrüger
was diese mit anzeigen quittierte
außerdem stellt der beiträge von tv
sendern und artikeln aus zeitschriften
ins internet und deren falsche
berichterstattung zu entlarven
diese urheberrechtsverletzungen wurden
teuer
besuch bei einem der hoffmanns
öffentlichen kampf seiner zeit
unterstützte der freie journalist und
viel markiert miete die haben mich ja
mehrfach versucht zu psychiatrie sieren
die gerichte und die richter und so
weiter und insgesamt sechsmal war das
davon war dreimal terminlich zwanzigster
vierter ok kennen sie den zwanzigsten 64
der wird nämlich wirklich nicht immer
hitlers geburtstag
okay wir machen die dann immer jetzt im
ernst da ist dann so eine verdeckte
mitteilung an den psychologen oder
psychiater der hat an weg also da
brauchen wir gar nicht genug und jetzt
mehr oder ja und oder die sagen dem wie
das urteil der psychiatrie sierung
aussehen soll
hoffmann zenit ist regional radiosendung
auf bisher auch miete post vom anwalt
des solar anbieters bekam und von
weiteren publikationen absehen musste
leider sagt miete denn er sei fasziniert
von querdenken wie daniele ganser fm und
rainer hoffmann müssen wir erstmal mit
aufgefahren er ist jemand der weiß
worüber er redet also in der tat ein
genialer kopf ein guter rhetoriker
jemand der sich richtig tief in sachen
einarbeiten kann und dort regelrecht
aufgeht
das fand ich total faszinierend da will
jemand was bewegen nein es überhaupt gar
kein spinner überhaupt ein im gegenteil
ist einfach zu schlau für den meisten
rainer hoffmann hat auf seiner seite www
solar kritik.de eine ganze reihe von
desinformation der tv sender
dokumentiert in der alternativen medien
hat sich hoffmann eine kleine
fangemeinde aufgebaut
auch das öffentlich-rechtliche fernsehen
berichtete über ihn seine solaranlage
und seinen kampf gegen die ihre führung
von konsumenten um das aber klar ist gar
nichts hauptstreitpunkt was sind
eigentlich 60 prozent des
warmwasserbedarfs
da gibt es zum beispiel den begriff
brauchwasser trinkwasser wärmebedarf
warmwasserbedarf die alle uneinheitlich
verwendet werden aber alle fast das
gleiche main und darstellen wenn dieser
schwindel durch nennen
letztlich ist ein schwindel den leuten
klar werden würde und das vehement in
der öffentlichkeit und in den medien
diskutiert werden würde dann würde ja im
grunde ein ganzer solar markt
zusammenbrechen die zahl der prozesse
zwischen hoffmann und der justiz stieg
jede zeile ein verfahren hoffmann gab
keine ruhe und war bei seinen verbalen
angriffen gegen die behörden
sicherlich nicht immer gut beraten die
behörden wurden auf ihn aufmerksam
das justizministerium in
nordrhein-westfalen legte eine 100 98
seitige akte über hofmann an deren
inhalt sei geheim zu halten befand ein
richter aus hoffmann einsicht verlangte
hoffmann geht davon aus dass diese
geheimakte unter verschluss gehalten
wird um zu vertuschen was bei seinen
prozessen alles schief gelaufen sei etwa
als auch das oberlandesgericht hamm
befand er sei nicht opfer eines betruges
geworden
[Applaus]
eine irreführung eines durchschnittlich
informierten und verständigen adressaten
sei in seinem fall nicht festzustellen
es geht um prozessbetrug um letztlich um
unterschlagung eines gutachtens und eben
das gericht hat die falsche werbeanzeige
in dem berufungsurteil verwendet das ist
ganz maßgeblich und eben nicht die
werbeanzeige die zum kaufvertrag im jahr
1996 geführt hat das ist die riesen
sauerei und das ist alles vom nrw
justizministerium in geheimen akten
seiten unter verschluss gehalten worden
das oberlandesgericht hamm bezog sich
auf ein verbraucherschutz urteil mit
dieser werbeanzeige und damit auf eine
andere als die die zum kauf von hofmann
solaranlage geführt hatte zentraler
unterschied laut hofmann in der einen
anzeige steht brauchwasser in der
anderen nicht als ich das mit den
werbeanzeigen und den datums werden
beweisen konnte fiel das ganze konstrukt
was sie über mich und gegenlicht
erstellt haben in sich zusammen und
seitdem bin ich bei den staatsfeind
nummer 1 pick sei
[Applaus]
die deutschen behörden sehen das ganz
anders alles sei stets korrekt
abgelaufen
unbestritten ist 2012 hoffmann in die
schweiz weil ihm in deutschland die
zwangs psychiatrie sierung drohte er
ließ alles zurück auch seine geliebte
mutter das schöne bruder sondern schöne
bude ja geht ja noch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der erste besuch nach sechs jahren im
exil wird zu einem wechselbad der
gefühle wird die ganze garage sind alles
deine akteur die ganze garage ist voll
hoffmann und seine mutter wohnten im
selben haus bis er floh und das haus
zwangsversteigert wurde
da hab ich mir eine flasche sekt
gekämpft
ein messer gekämpft haben wir die
pulsadern aufgeschnitten und habe mich
in uhr auf dem friedhof auf unser
familiengrab wo meine mutter 1944
beerdigt wurde das grab existiert noch
da hab ich nicht drauf gelegt sie warum
stellt ja ich wollte stern die brote die
adern pulsadern aufgeschnitten und da
muss wohl noch nachts jemand dumm
gelaufen sein
und der hat mich ja man gehört und die
polizei gerufen weil rechts und links
ist nichts sind sie froh im nachhinein
dass sie gerettet wurden
nee eigentlich nicht wieso ich nicht
leben weil ich was hatte ich denn ich
hatte ja nix ich hatte ja nix
es war ein scheiß wert auf das geld oder
auf der ausweis doch drauf soja ist
ärgerlich aber irgendwo also ich weiß
wie ich hab dir heute gesehen nicht
zusammen mit einigen neuen aktenordner
und geht es zurück in die schweiz
[Gelächter]
wobei die aussichten auch in der schweiz
trüb sind
er führt seinen kampf sozusagen aus dem
untergrund weiter gegen die deutsche
justiz und die solarindustrie und neu
auch gegen klimaforscher die von einer
gefährlichen klimaerwärmung reden
alles quatsch sagt hoffmann und deckt
medien die aus seiner sicht falsch über
den klimawandel berichten mit
beschwerden ein
so auch das treffen bisher erfolglos
die psychiater erklärend mich quasi für
den spieler viel ich bin hier wirklich
eine hat sie im moment gehe ich nie ich
weiß das doch wirklich nach hofmann
versteckt sich seit sechs jahren vor der
deutschen justiz und psychiatrie
halberstadt ein freund aus besseren
zeiten und ebenfalls ein skeptiker in
sachen klima forschung unterstützt ihn
mit rat tat und geld hoffmann ist
nirgendwo angemeldet hat keine
krankenkasse und keine arbeit
was kann sie dann für eine perspektive
für ihn ist das konto wir jetzt keine
perspektive in dem sinn dass ich sage
das konto das und kurz und gut kann
internet das ist sie dass ich sie ja
klar sei damals locker wenn er darüber
kommt und wie lange würde sie nur
unterstützen
ich hoffe dass das landleben wenn sie
morgen im duo sind ja dass ich mich
momentan sei es eine win win situation
sagen kostet und hoffman rain muss um
viertel vor fünf weg genau geht alles
gut kommt die nächste abgerockt dienst
dh hoffmann hilfe bei der betreuung
seiner schwer dementen frau brigitte sie
ist in einem pflegeheim untergebracht
ob man holt sie täglich für einen
spaziergang abhilfe beim essen und macht
ausflüge mit dir heute geht's in die
partie klar ist für immer wird diese win
win situation nicht weiter bestehen
bossert ist inzwischen 80 hoffmann mitte
50 der eine könnte irgendwann sterben
der antritt zb krank werden
spätestens dann wird es schwierig um
nicht zu sagen aussichtslos sicher habe
ich mein heutiges leben auch anders
geplant aber
da sehe ich nicht nur die schuld bei mir
oder kaum bei mir weil ich immer
eigentlich ehrlich das gesagt was
letztlich fakt war und nur einige leute
wollten das nicht wahrhaben dass das
eben die fakten sind weil da ganz andere
leute plötzlich probleme kriegen das
wollte man ja nicht dass diese wichtigen
leute probleme kriegen und dann hat man
niemand mich als kleinen man
entsprechend vernichtet
warum nimmt diese geschichte eine
unerwartete wendung auf man nun bossert
hatten einen heftigen streit post sagte
hoffmann solle abhauen was dieser auch
tat
bald aber bedauert die post das ganze
und meldete hoffmann bei der polizei als
vermisst
inzwischen haben sich die gemüter
beruhigt aber die polizei und das
migrationsamt wurden auf hofmann
aufmerksam
er müsse seiner meldepflicht nachkommen
wurde ihm beschieden also täter die
flucht nach vorne an
weil er definitiv gefährlich sei für die
juristin und deutschland beantragt
politisches asyl in der schweiz
ich weiß so viel über die justiz in
deutschland und deren machenschaften
und insofern bin ich gefährlich für die
justiz in deutschland und das ist mein
problem deswegen kann ich eigentlich
darf ich eigentlich nicht nach
deutschland zurückgeschickt werden weil
es auch eine bedrohung für mein leben
bedeuten würde
man wird mich wahrscheinlich nicht töten
man wird mich mit psychopharmaka mundtot
machen wollen das wird die
vorgehensweise sein
man darf gespannt sein wie es mit einer
hofmann weitergeht